m
[Musique]
ce qui sera acquis
présente-toi domino et quoi ton truc at
war et j'ai beaucoup de chance si la
chance est pas un super pouvoir
messi mais non d'à côté pour moi les
choses qui me sont toujours bien
ouah mais c'est pas super pouvoirs
expliqué
et s'ils sont nés
on va
on coupe la poire en deux on n'a qu'à
dire non à recaser qu'est ce que j'ai
comme chose
wedde ton coeur est juste si tu
t'entraînes toi aussi tu peux être x man
x men c'est pas ma canne mais alors pas
du tout parce que tu n'es pas on m'a
déjà des puces clé
je le protégerai contre câbles mais tout
seul je peux pas je suis à x manager ta
gueule hélas tout et sinon tu craques
justin bieber a tu as vu toutes apprises
pour justin bieber était paré ont dit
qu'un bouffon déguisé en jouant très le
monarque
tu es sûr que tu viens pas l'univers dc
comics